non pensavo che l'avrei mai detto ma
oggi riprende scusate se gli occhiali
sono più decente formino così credo il
blog massa
lo scorso anno la prima puntata l'ho
iniziata con luigi e la tradizione per
quanto mi riguarda è tradizione e quello
che è stato forse uno dei momenti più
apprezzati in realtà fra vari è stato
quello dell'albero che l'anno scorso
abbiamo fatto completamente attaccato al
muro è ribaltato quest'anno abbiamo
pensato di fare la stessa cosa però poi
ci siamo detti no cerchiamo di superarci
vedevo di farci venire un'idea che non
avessimo già fatto non so se riusciremo
a farcela perché è un pochino tosta però
mai dire mai è ottimista possiamo
spiegare che cosa abbiamo pensato di
tempio musica è presente quelle del che
processi ma ok il prezzo è giusto anzi
quella delle letterine
non ho amore un punto guardavi po
abbiamo anzi sono due o tre aerei ancora
troppo piccolo questo qui è l'idea come
lo chiamiamo per il momento in maniera
provvisoria albero che si teletrasporta
spesa tutte le arme la tele a mero
albero porto non lo so dal royal c le
voci non ne abbiamo poche ore qui
l'albero che vorremmo mettere che
vorremmo mente al contrario mentre
quella di la punta che sbuca a questo è
l'angoletto organo predestinato io non
ne so niente
l offesa che le arrabbiatissima e
offesissima messa all'angolo le solo
come tre baby nati e poi abbiamo un
pochino un set di palline sì avevo un po
di palline e così ne sono diciamo
avanzate negli anni qui abbiamo bisogno
di altro per un salto a comprare tutto
quello che ci serve per tutti gli
effetti speciali di cui abbiamo bisogno
mi sento macgyver quando facciamo queste
forme natale ormai e ci tengo ad avere
un ringraziamento particolare perché
avrebbero risparmiato un'ora e un quarto
di acquisti dall'europa lanna manco
stessimo mettendo in piedi nuovo set di
star trek ci fermiamo un attimo a
mangiare un po di pizza precedente
ingegneristica pura ingegneristica
ingegneria fame
il caratterino il muco natalizio tipo
qui che ne dici un po più a destra c'è
più li ritroviamo un po più a sinistra
per donarsi ok è stata bloccata
adesso faremo cose ma che preparare il
muro per appendere un lancio però deciso
che è natale tutto vale ok e quindi a me
poi che aveva come fare stocchero tra
adattare a parlare perché non mi aspetto
che tutti in paese qualche mio io con
lei possiamo sbloccare tutto se
piazziamo lacchiarella qua più o meno
arriva all'altezza di questo rischia di
piegarsi fortemente ma è l'unica chance
che abbiamo creato svago invece che
spiegherà prima o poi ancora non abbiamo
idea di come fare a montare il cosa su
ma creiamo i portali in modo da per
l'aci che era un'idea ci verrà
rivoluzione frattempo no
beh stiamo cento conferma sto facendo i
buchi neri che sono diciamo i passaggi
da una dimensione all'altra cercando di
creare il tubo la vedo molto difficile
secondo me alternativa valida e spiega
di provare con il fil di ferro pareti
una sorta di cappio lino così ritiri in
trento davvero così vai che comunichiamo
al mondo in aereo
quanto sei genio allora speriamo questa
piccola cosa
luigi e io abbiamo appena finito di
litigare perché lui pensava di saper
fare tutto quanto questo che di ferro
avrebbe passato qua dentro e poi a
quella del attaccato delucis t9 di rete
come andare idea che a un certo punto
cioè a due centimetri
no limits amenta cm prodotti ei 20 cm 30
fatto sta che alla fine ho attaccato un
piccolo pezzetto a un filo che è passato
perfettamente dentro al filo attaccato
lo spago che è passato perfettamente
interessa allo spacco attaccheremo
quello lì che star bassi altrettanto
perfettamente dentro
grazie luce un grande oddio ma è tutto
certamente muscoli non va si rompe
se si rompe tutto accendiamo avevo come
perché sei un pazzesco è fighissimo
[Applauso]
s'è spezzata quante allora vorrei
solamente vedere quello che ormai rimane
di questo angolana cucchiara e 27 buchi
fatti inutilmente nostro passando per
che fino abbiamo staccato la plafoniera
quella roba lì scrostata a ruolo per
infilarci il gancio e quello che sto
buco nero che in questo momento se posso
essere sincero mi fa cagare comuni fa
cagare qualsiasi altra cosa abbiamo
montato la prima parte non so se si vede
intanto è lì bisogna fare 200 altre cose
lo è uscito dopo essersi sfondato le
dita a creare anche portare più largo
bravo lo studiando anche giugno scritto
ha tentato adeguando il prossimo anno
421 sfocati nismo guardate non tifa
inter c'è quasi tutte le 22
io ho paura che però gli enti la doccia
si rispetto a quello sì
[Musica]
avanguardia pura ecco la prima inter
momento che tutti questi hanno gli
attacchi del cavolo con tutti gli
attacchi quelli li sto facendo 2 in
combo più lei che sei porta via
c'è un genio a questo punto voi direte
ma scusa ma stiamo incasinati qua sopra
come faremo con lei
faremo l'effetto kakà di aral e che
nasconderà il groviglio di fili pesa
molto non so come farà a non correre
tutto io aspetto quel crollo nella notte
sapeva sapeva per certo questa mattina
del mese ma non sarà un messaggio sarà
una foto e l'altra toni impazzendo
impazzendo
ma io sto impazzendo io sto impazzare
succede voglio distruggere tutto perché
non si attacca niente sul noi
l'ostentazione del basket aiuto
praticate anch'io
riprendendo è giusto un po di verità
sono frustrato ce la faccio più costa me
questo è quello che ho fatto io
in un momento di follia totale o
scocciato qualsiasi cosa non lo fa
perché voi non fate anche voi non so
quanto sia pericoloso se c'è qualcuno là
fuori che mi può dire quanto stai
rischiando la vita e lo faccia sapere
no io questo qua mi sento questo
ciao ciao festa con piacere
ciao ebbene dezza non ci ami a quando
non una lite di averti ios o perdere del
seno io mister rastelli soldi in grassi
quella sera la cavano severa è normale
siamo in vostro soccorso è buio netto
scendo sun pazza ritorno natale fa
schifo cosa per natale spero diventi
foto in grassi un bello il rally è
l'albero al contrario di nuovo tra dove
decide trasporta colava diventi ho
portato un po di cioccolato
e tiene i piedi e per tempo ora questo
qui fa un po la mente questo è meglio
alza e lascia batta sopra sì sì sì mezzo
che non sapeva come farlo è stato posto
dai si sa non c'è niente come un albero
normale lo faresti come fattori ma le
luci ha fatto tutto io sono rimasto
aggrappato
ma come fate a natale palline al
contrario come l'anno scorso non cascano
non la guarda pure quello che cosa le
palle vietatissimi ve ne sono cascate
diversi perché lì è cassonetto cioè se
voi aveste addosso un quarto della mia
fatica voi non ridere ste nemmeno
guglielmo centro che magari c'è qui
dietro non vedo rivali degli elbow vabbè
ci servono le parole dietro ci sono atti
a bando e al bagno mi sto solo
martellando di vita non ci sta bene un
cavo di cucina dell'abbraccio
perché tanto potresti far credere che
questo non esiste mi sto uscendo
lentamente da bene in effetti posso dire
che passa proprio inosservato quello che
dico io nel momento in cui lo vedi cs
dicendo ma c'è pure questo qui
ma tu dove sei impazzito perché mi sono
detto seguire così scopo io la mia parte
certe grandi anche ripreso strappato
molto non so chi sono le poverina messa
all'angolo denunciati da un orecchino
ecco qui ma equa perde pezzi crociana
perché io ho una spiegazione scientifica
poco e poi ancora riscattato stavo nel
buco sbagliato e mi ha dato un regalino
ma che belli le fatti tu o lampadine
sono allora il presente per scherzo lupi
dice che sono foca guardato il codino
ma tutto tour è dipinto in una patina
fatta con la vedi tu hai fatto una
lampadina con l'acrilico e madama e
dolcissima questa sera veni alle zampe
alla codina v e poi c'è un pinguino che
forse preferisco il mio utero chi è o
può dire ring odio
[Applauso]
siamo io e lui lui carino ma io sono fra
quei mini alberello un albero che si
teletrasporta poter dominare
l'idea di luigi del cd no culto non ci
provare nemmeno le foto pressatura
dell'anno scorso l'uomo
noi dobbiamo scappare perché ti sta
partendo il treno grazie ciao
sono tornato dalla stazione di burda e
mezzo che al buio sia molto piccolo sarà
infatti in un velo di spegnere le luci
già amico che vuole notevole
pochissimo è inoltre rincara la
situazione avere un'altra cosa ma è
bellissima questa atmosfera un po per
natale beh io posso dire che lo sforzo
che hai fatto che questo pomeriggio ha
funzionato da visioni oggi si si guarda
non ero rimasto colpiti simo all'inizio
ma vista da questo punto di vista mi
piace ci sta già quella dell'anno scorso
io una segheria dietro tutti animate di
facciata hai messo dei perego centri
nola queste lui queste due sono
deliziose si sono ballardini sa che a
natale le riuscito sono sincronizzate
cioè se è un portale devono essere
sincronizzate perché pure il come vedi
questo adesso si sta alternando così
come si è visto praticamente se lo
faremo un'altra volta
io direi a questo punto che la prima
giornata di vogue ma finisce qui i
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto noi
tanto ci vediamo domani con un'altra
puntata
ciao
[Musica]
si no